on continue avec une autre nommé de
cette catégorie meilleure actrice
virginie efira bonsoir vous êtes
magnifiques jeux renversés pour vous est
rayonnant merci et je ne vous cache pas
que vous faites partie des dd non favori
en tout cas votre prestation dans adieu
les qu'on a vraiment enchanté ému fait
rire je rappelle film d'albert dupontel
l'un des films les plus nommés ce soit
qu'est ce que ça fait de plonger dans
l'univers d'albert dupontel
l'univers d'albert dupontel basse et
c'est une expérience qui est assez
inoubliable quand même parce que je
pense que c'est une des personnes que
j'ai rencontrées qui a le plus de
d'amour et de croyances pour le cinéma
avec une exigence qui est mise à un
niveau supérieur sur le fond sur la
forme il ya des côtés des gens qui se
connaissaient déjà nicolas marie avait
travaillé avec lui ça cinéma particulier
aux six ya quelque chose à la fois oui
bien sûr et c'est à la fois ci c'est
comme s'il fallait rentrer dans une
image qui existaient déjà et les prendre
vie quand même quoi c'était pas mal
c'était pas mal alors il est pas présent
ce soir pour des raisons qui lui sont
propres et ce que vous avez dans l avais
parlé des dénominations avec lui comment
est ce qui venant du film je pense qu'il
fait c'est filmé avec une conscience
extrêmement forte du public et chez
prioritairement ça qui le qui
l'intéressent le film a une vie courte
en salle 7 jours c'est un non sens en
séance le soir et qui a très bien marché
quand même 600 mille entrées voilà donc
c'est comme si on n'avait pas mis à
rennes est comme si on avait mis pause
et c'est un film qui a le mérite
effectivement d'à la fois pouvoir
toucher un public extrêmement large tout
en ayant une consistance et une densité
cinématographique forte donc j'ai
confiance en la possibilité il retrouve
un public
vous avez été nommé quatre fois aux
césars deux fois pour des fans pour des
films réalisés par des femmes justine
trier catherine corsini vous avez
l'impression que les choses changent
pour les femmes dans le cinéma
est ce que les choses changent pour les
femmes dans le cinéma après il ya des
hommes très féminin paul verhoeven par
exemple donc voilà il n'y a pas est-ce
que les choses changent oui en tout cas
50/50 fait un travail est évident pour
la parité et plein d'autres aussi il ya
une conscience enfin c'est à dire je ne
sais pas si on peut dire dans le cinéma
ou partout ailleurs c'est à dire ya
quand même une conscience appartements
les choses sont nommés une remise en
question de chacun en fait sur ce qu'est
un rapport à l'autre sur ce que c'est
que filmer quelqu'un sur ce que c'est
que travailler ensemble et ça rejaillit
évidemment dans le cinéma oui alors vous
avez une réplique dans le film ça votre
personnage qui s'appelle sus d'ailleurs
je t'aime sont les mots les plus
importants à dire dans une vie oui
partager cette opinion de votre
personnage ils ont pensé parce que ben
oui je pense quand même oui voilà et ce
soit clôturée peut-être faisons-nous une
grande déclaration d'amour au ciné
c'était et moi j'avais envie de vous
faire une déclaration d'amour et de dire
je t'aime virginie efira bonne chance
merci merci à vous